- Some ASMR stuff right here.
It's like the sound
of when you walk on the crisp
autumn leaves, you know?
Hey, everyone, this is Inga
and I am super excited to be here today
to make one of the most
extravagant recipes
from Tasty's new cookbook,
"Tasty Over the Top."
It has a lot of creative
and inspiring new recipes
that kinda celebrate
what Tasty is known for:
showstopping, Instaworthy,
very visual recipes
that are as fun to make
as they are to eat.
Today, I'm gonna be making
the Rainbow Unicorn Babka,
and the reason I picked this recipe
is because, well, I love bread,
I love playing around with colors.
This recipe uses natural food
coloring, matcha and pitaya,
two of my favorite flavors.
So let's get started.
Hair's tied.
I'm gonna start off by
making the yeast mixture.
First thing I'm gonna do is
actually melt some butter
and we're gonna set it down.
I'm gonna go ahead and add in
the sugar now, milk as well.
This is the base of something good.
You already know that.
Add in the yeast.
Oh, it smells so good already actually.
Let it rest for about 10 minutes.
Perfect time for a snack
break if you're asking me
so I'm gonna go do that
and we'll be right back.
I'm back with some more dry ingredients.
I have two bowls of flour here
because we're gonna make two
different colored doughs,
one with matcha and one with pitaya.
I'm gonna put the pitaya in this one
and then I'm gonna put
the matcha in this one
and a little bit of salt.
For the pitaya, I'm gonna add in an egg.
My yeast mixture as you can
see is now split into two bowls
and one I'm going to put right in here
and we're just going to combine this now.
Ooh, okay, look at that pink.
I think this is actually pretty
well combined at this point
and this is gonna rest for 30 minutes.
In the meantime, I'm gonna
work on my matcha dough.
All right, so now I have
my two bowls of dough here.
They're gonna rest for 30 minutes,
get a little beauty sleep,
and we'll be right back.
Okay, so while the dough is resting,
I'm actually gonna get
started on the icing.
I'm gonna go ahead and put
some butterfly pea flower
into my warm milk here.
I'm going to give it a
little bit of a stir.
Already, it's actually already changing
the color a little bit.
I'm going to let this sit
here for around an hour.
All right, friends,
I have my beautifully
risen dough babies here.
As you can see, they are now super puffy.
Wow, it is soft.
This brings me so much satisfaction.
Little flour action.
Oh my gosh.
Gonna roll it out.
I'm trying to aim for a
six by 12 inch rectangle.
The measurements actually
do matter a little bit
and I think this is looking
pretty good honestly.
Just to make sure.
All right, friends, first rectangle, done.
We good to move on?
And same thing.
Just gonna roll this out.
And now what we're gonna do
is actually marry the two.
Essentially pinch them together like so
so they form one dough.
Now that I have that together,
I am going to actually
brush on some melted butter.
So no holding back.
Babka is a treat.
And then the next thing I'm gonna do
is add on some fruity cereal.
This is a very nostalgic flavor for me
and I honestly just also
love the crunch here.
Think that looks pretty good.
That looks pretty good.
Am I being too generous?
Okay, I think I'm a little
too greedy here already.
All right, great.
Just gonna go in with my
hands here and just...
Hear that?
This is some, some ASMR stuff right here.
It's like the sound of
when you walk in the woods
on the crisp autumn leaves, you know?
This is art.
This is straight up
just art, look at that.
This could belong in the MoMA.
It is looking pretty good to
me so I am going to roll it up.
This is a slightly trickier
part but we're gonna go for it.
Oh my gosh.
Y'all, look at that.
We have a beautiful dual
colored cylinder thing going on.
What I wanna do is
actually cut it in half.
Okay, we're just gonna go for it
and just try to cut it in half here.
This is where we play
like really intense music
because like, is, ooh.
One last cut here all the
way down in the middle.
The reveal.
Ooh, look at that.
Okay, it's a little,
little crazy right now,
but you can see the cross section here.
This is the part where
because we're making a babka,
we're gonna try and twist it together
by doing a crisscross here.
Same thing on this end.
Looks pretty good, if I do say so myself.
Okay, great.
Just put this, this big
guy in there carefully.
Help.
Okay.
Carefully scoop this up and
just place it right in there.
Oh my gosh.
Ah.
Oh, the panic I had for a second.
Okay, amazing.
So now that I have this,
I am pretty much ready
to go bake this now.
So while the babka is baking in the oven,
I am going to finish the icing
that I started a little while ago.
As you can see, this milk
is now a very, very nice shade of blue.
I'm gonna make two
different colored icings.
One is blue and one will be purple.
All right, we're just gonna start off
by making a big batch of blue.
Put that in the powdered
sugar that we have here
and gently mix that up.
All right, this is looking pretty good.
I'm going to separate some
out and make my purple icing.
This is like a little magic trick
because if you add lemon to
butterfly pea flower tea,
it will become purple.
You see how it becomes violet?
And there you go.
Ready for decoration.
I think now it's about
time to check on the babka.
Okay, look at how good that looks.
The smell's amazing.
Smells like buttery brioche-y bread.
The fruity cereal, just, I love
how it clung onto the dough.
And now to add some decoration.
I'm gonna start with the blue icing here.
Oh my gosh.
All right, now let's do the purple icing.
Oh my gosh, this is a lot
but you know, that's what
we're aiming for today.
And now I'm going to add sprinkles
because you can never
have enough sprinkles.
Maybe a little bit more.
Why not?
There's some little stars here
that I'm just gonna add
to complete the look.
Little pearls on there too.
Why not?
We're going for extravagant
so extravagant it is.
This is it.
This is the Rainbow Unicorn Babka.
There's a lot of colors going on.
It is very sparkly.
I'm very excited to cut
into this and taste it.
I wonder if it's gonna
taste as fun as it looks.
All right, it is time to cut this bread.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Smells amazing.
Smells buttery, brioche-y.
I'm gonna take a big bite here.
Oh yeah, that's some good bread.
Honestly, what I really love about this
is the texture of the fruity cereal
and like the little pops of fruity flavor.
I actually do taste the matcha
and the icing kinda just
brings it all together.
This is really good.
But really, making this babka
was such a fun experience.
I love that we got to play around
with so many different colors,
so many different flavors.
It all came together
to create this like beautiful
sort of, like, centerpiece.
And honestly, there's so many
more fun recipes like that
in this book, "Tasty Over the Top,"
that I'm also very excited to try.
I really think that this
is a great cookbook to have
if you want to impress
your friends, your family.
Really, I also think this
cookbook would be a perfect gift.
This is something I would wanna give
to my friends and family
'cause I want them to have
fun when they're cooking
and just enjoy these new experiences.
So yeah, go get the
cookbook if you haven't yet,
"Tasty Over the Top."
You're gonna have so much fun with this.
It's the perfect gift and
I will see y'all later.
(calm music)